hello everyone
scp049 again
today we're going to be playing
the anniversary edition
of surgeon simulator
i just thought i'd give you a little
preview
on the ancient
computer device
britannia 1988 and as you can see
on the screen
we have the eyeball
transplant
very good
so
as we proceed to the operations you can
see that the layout has somewhat changed
but it's quite easy to get used to see
eyeball surgery
so without any further ado
let's start
now
i think first of all what i want to do
is just clear
the workspace
of everything that i
really don't need
i think i might need these but i just
like to get rid of the
the jars
that's about to fall off there let me
just
just pick that up
[Music]
and
wow
okay that was an experience
[Music]
okay so if i just move these
to the side so that
unpleasant accent doesn't happen again
throw the hammer out of the way as it's
pretty much useless in this let's play
and if i use the scalpel to cut the
headband that attaches the goals to the
head
oh sorry they're all chip
completely involuntary
just gently go in try not to stab him
again
and
there we go
it just
falls off
no need to bash it with a hammer
a bunch of savages
so i'm just positioning the head there
for this surgery
it is quite unconventional
as the most effective way of dislodging
the eyes
is using a pencil
you may be thinking this is mad
but i have seen a lot of other people
using
far more brutal implements
to do this and
i really want to cause
as little suffering as possible
that is a common misconception people
have about me
so if i could just lift this pencil
and here comes the hard bit
to actually
stab the eye
it is quite
tricky
if i could
sometimes this
game
generally does oh there we go
[Music]
finally
i'm fairly saddened i stabbed him in the
eye at least five times there
but i could be wrong i'm not infallible
as you can see the right eye is kind of
protruding now so it is dislodged
and if i could just get the other one
this is quite frustrating
as the head
always moves around
so there is no
scientific way of approaching this you
just have to thrust forward and hope for
the best
and there we go the right eye
is skewed so if i could just
grab this pencil again
pull it out
and there we go
our patient bulba looking quite scary at
this moment
i wonder if i could just
dislodge the eye using the pencil
i don't think that's working so
unfortunately
i'm going to have to use my hands
just to yes
applying pressure to the side of the
head generally works
the official guidelines say you must use
the small hammer
but i would much rather be hit with a
hand
than a small hammer
so now in the surgery i must grab the
scalp
and sever
all the muscles that connect the eye
to the eye socket
and as before
there is no real scientific way
to approach this as
not only the head is moving constantly
but also the optic nerves
and the eyes and the muscles it's
it's a cluster
really
sorry sorry to use language like that
but i
i really do get quite annoyed
i've worked in many hospitals and
securing the head in one place generally
is quite an easy thing
to do after all if you look down
his body is fastened
to the chair
quite well
so if i could just
there we go there is the two eyes
completely dislodged
so if i could just
do this
and
i'm getting ahead of myself a little bit
first of all i need to empty these
bottles of eyes
so if i could just tip this
they should all fall out
[Music]
an eight ball there
this game is very amusing
very
amusing i only got two out of five not
not the best
turn out there
and one of the eyes
from the first bottle is a smiley face
which is not really conducive to proper
2020 vision
although it can make quite a good
fashion statement
okay
i've got plenty to
choose from here
oh
i think the makers of this game really
need to sort out some bugs
because
they clearly just teleported under the
first section of the table there
so if i just plug the eyeballs with the
pencil
and bring them inside
the socket
i wonder if i could just fetch the eyes
from underneath
no it doesn't look like it
oh well
a normal eye it is
so if i can just
grab a butter fingers
to get another pencil here
hopefully it won't be too hard to secure
there we go
i can just gently
put this in
and there you have it
i hope you enjoyed
the eyeball surgery
i look forward to seeing you all again
next time
and as always
i am the cure
so if i just
oh
my lord
are you joking me
are you joking me right now my scalpel
is stuck in a
so if i just put this pencil here
sorry
the pencils
the pencil just disappeared
am i high